okay so a good afternoon so I'm just
going to do a few slide
a long demo so I'm gonna talk about life
programming this is a term that has many
different meanings but I'm going to talk
about the specific meaning that I'm
going to use here so programming has
been an evolution of getting more and
more interactivity so we started off
with you know back at the beginning we
had cables then we had punch cards and
teletypes and finally we get terminals
and stuff right and then today we have
multi-monitor setups but you know
programming is still sort of like a but
where we really want to go is we want to
go to what's the future like how is
programming in and become more
interactive right and we kind of see a
hint of this in movies in these fake
user interfaces but will we ever be able
to realize those today programming is
really like archery you you aim your
arrow that's your editing you let your
arrow go you're debugging and you see
where it lands and then you start again
and every time you do that you you edit
you you you debug and then you edit
again and you debug again it's not a
very continuous experience so there's a
lot of discontinuity discontinuity there
and what we really want is water hosing
so there's an Olympic sport for archery
there's not an Olympic sport for hitting
targets with a water hose because it's
really easy you just move your water
hose over and you hit your target right
and I think this is a kind of experience
that we want for programming if we can
achieve it and I think that really goes
a long way and for us to realize sort of
the next generation of programming
interfaces okay so we're gonna improve
the feedback loop between the programmer
in the computer and I'm gonna do a demo
here there's a lot of things that some
of you might have seen before I think
I've stole their ideas from a lot of
really great people
Chris Hancock and his live programming
dissertation is one of my big influences
and then the victor of course you know
describing calculator and learn herbal
programming I mean
there's not a direct connection to live
programming there but I think the
connection is natural and obvious and
Alexander repeating in his
conversational programming work so I'm
just going to start with a demo and just
continue on with it and let's see what's
my old key here okay good alright and I
don't want to see that go away
all right good trying to get Windows to
hide the taskbar as impossible all right
so I'm gonna start my I'm gonna sit down
here because I can't do a lot of typing
so I'm gonna start off with a question
mark
and I know and Chris mangers talk he was
he was using the question mark for
something a bit different but here it
means a whole something unknown and it
applies real estate to that syntactic
real estate to that concept we can probe
it and we can see that it's a void type
because all statements are our void and
we can actually perform code completion
on this so I'm gonna code complete we
don't have a lot of void methods right
now but we have draw insert into asset
insert a lot of items into asset log but
from a dictionary and so I'm going to
choose draw now I'm gonna hit return
here and we've now our drawing something
on the screen right and we have more I
call these holy terms right with an e so
it's not religious but we have all these
holy terms here one is what are we
drawing some random geometry the color
of what we're drawing in green and then
pen and the index which is we're not
using so these holy terms have default
or random values depending on the
context so as soon as I complete on draw
I get a bunch of holy terms they have
values and something is drawn on the
screen over here all right we don't have
to wait I can Co complete on this holy
term again and we get circle condition
hexagon Pentagon and we get a lot of
other choices that might make sense in
certain contexts but are not in entirely
high priority all right so let's pick a
you know hexagon okay so now we get a
heck
on the screen okay and we can fill in
the position here you know ten hundred
by 100 let me make this give us a little
bit more space on the code side I can
take that I'll take that way if I need
it so and then we can give it a size 100
give me my keyboard back 100 and maybe a
color it would be nice here just do coke
completion there blue okay so it made a
bunch of discrete modifications here
well let's just do it like this okay I
made a much a bunch of discrete
modifications here but it's not really
continuous right
you know if I'm if I'm editing my code
right and I have to type you know if I
want to go from 100 to 200 I have to
delete the one and type it to the same
here right and that's not very nice
right I mean it's yeah okay you get you
get to see the result wide awake this
this hexagon is just jumping all over
the place right
so let's you know do something called
scrubbing so I mean scrubbing is this
concept I think it's from audio visual
field but I think right Victor kind of
defined it in the computer field where
you know you're editing values via
continuous input so we're going to take
200 we're going to go back to 100 here
and or okay 102 fine I know how to use a
mouse
sometimes it depends on my how nervous I
am all right well whatever close enough
right but the thing is is that as we do
this scrubbing we can see you know it
moves continuously we can I it right we
have a water hose before we didn't have
a water hose before we had a very fancy
bow and arrow and now we have a water
hose for real
okay we can also scrub let's say on the
entire two pole right so now we're just
moving it around you know via to the
input and this is possible because the
type of this tuple is position so we're
using type inference it's going to the
tuple and saying hey you're really a
position and that's being used by the
scrubbing system to say okay well we
know how to scrub position with this 2d
widget so type system types are actually
static types are actually useful but you
not seeing these static types here
because we have inference and that's why
inference is useful right we can do the
same thing with you know the size and
again it's a length
it's a length one and it knows how to
scrub that it's not just it's not just a
number right it's it the size is
actually limited to the size of this
related to the size of the screen and we
can also scrub colors all right we're
gonna click here and we get a bunch of
colors and we can scrub that right so
okay because maybe crimson is a nice
color for this hexagon we can do more
than that right we can kill this and
make it a tuple because you know color
is just a three dimensional thing right
and we can look at this two bullets it's
going to be a color right and we can
actually see well maybe there's a custom
scrubbing widget for that right and now
we can choose a nice you know you know
custom color for it as opposed to a
literal color that is preset okay and
finally we have shape we can scrub shape
right we can make it a Pentagon triangle
rectangle let me stop there and let's go
up square or circle okay so we can scrub
that and it's quite useful right now
deciding what you're gonna do is grab a
shape okay so let me go in
some boilerplate code here I don't want
the windows icon okay so now I've reset
the simulation and I mean I reset the
code and that's horrible
let's see if I can make that a little
bit nicer okay just give them our space
okay
now I'm going to make a bouncy ball
right so we're gonna set the position to
be PEP is up here it's a sign to it's a
variable assigned to a holy term as soon
as we assign P right here it's just any
it doesn't have any meaning see show it
to me any okay but as soon as I type it
here right this holy term is now a
position and it has a value because
positions have default random values as
their default as their evaluation and a
holy thing right and then we can you
know set the diameter of the circle to
be D and it's again it's given a value
when we make that and let's say well
let's Center it because our position is
the left right the left top position we
want it to be the center so we can do
physics calculations on it so let's
subtract that right now we get this nice
now the position is here we're gonna
move that out and it creates this this
term called RR it's gonna be you know
initialized to a holy trim and I'm just
gonna drag that here and move that code
up okay now I should mention here that
this is a cyst this is a programming
language it's imperative it's not
declarative it's not dataflow it's not
functional it's it's imperative but it
has react like features so now I'm going
to do this on tick here which is on
every tick time tick and I'm going to do
something with the position I'm just
going to add the velocity because
there's this beak
I'm sorry pointing in my screen there's
a V up there here that we can actually
use to do something with that now what
happens is that once I've done that
right the there's a strobing there's a
there's a strobe here that does 200
frames and it samples at every twenty
ten frames so it's executing it up to
200 frames in attempt and then ever
be ten frames or so it's it's being
sampled right but we can control where
we see the ball in time by scrubbing on
tick right this is not changing the tick
event this is scrubbing what tick event
were we're visualizing an tick event
goes off every frame so every 15
milliseconds or so okay so we can scrub
that we can actually see where the ball
is and we're gonna do the same for
velocity now we have a falling ball and
of course we don't want that ball to
fall off the screen so let's go ahead
and clamp it but to do that I'm going to
have to create a new position here
holy term again I'm gonna move this up
okay what do me wrong here I'm gonna
clamp it co completion clamp is right
there code completion again let's look
for the minimum okay our our was what's
the size of the the radius of the circle
and then we just need the screen size
now we see the ball oh well it's kind of
clamped but not really it's falling to
the bottom of the screen so we need to
subtract RR from here
hey no no it's sir now what's up okay
and we need to do something else with
the velocity to make it bounce off the
screen so we're going to multiply that
by this inflect command down here let's
see what p1 + RR now it's a bouncing
ball okay
so now the inflect one is to find down
here it's just user defined function
that does something based on the screen
size let me make that smaller yeah this
is good enough
okay keep running out of screen real
estate here when I picked up the font
okay now I'm going to create an
abstraction so we're gonna define the
single ball and it's it's body is just
gonna be a holy turn and I'm going to
drag the holy term down to this plus and
move that all up and since ball is not
being called it just disappears right
because we're no longer drawing a ball
we just created a method that draws up
all we're going to find a for loop here
I and zero until two and then we're just
gonna call Paul yeah actually it's a
coefficient for that
there it is me get two balls okay so now
if I drag that again you can woo
that's because if I'm running out of
space but if I scroll down I can
actually do it okay okay now we're gonna
do plug this or we're gonna you know at
least inspect it right so I'm going to
do this control I'm gonna select the
ball in my new control G and I just type
control G and I went down two lines to
the ball of definition and I just didn't
navigate to the ball definition I I set
the execution context the debug
execution context of the ball method to
the ball that was being executed on this
line right now if I probe I can probe
any value here and I can see the color
so this is the purple one that's sorry
putting the screen again I gotta get out
of that habit the purple one the lower
ball that the one that's purple on the
other ones kind of red right and now I
can actually make that stick there so I
can put a little @ symbol here and make
that stick as meta text in the program
and I can I can probe other things here
I can probe the position for example and
the velocity or whatever but you know
there's there's more there's two balls
here actually there might be more than
that there might be eight balls here
okay hi this is just scrubbing on the
the loop the bounds of the loop right so
and you can do that life too so it's
kind of cool
which ball am i viewing and viewing the
purple one this this one right here but
what if I want to view the other one or
the other one or the other one are they
women or there's brown ball down here
which is the last one right so I can
scrub on the iteration variable to scrub
through space so I can scrub on tick to
scrub through time and I can scrub on I
to scrub through the space and I'm
hitting the top of the screen but that's
okay I can scrub multiple times if I
don't have enough space all right you
just hit return all right let's do it
that way okay now let's look let's do a
little bit of debugging here let's just
kind of look at how this thing works
let me find something interesting okay
let's go with the brown one hitting the
bottom of the screen okay now I'm gonna
go scrub to the to the brown one right
and now I'm going to look at the inflect
call here I'm going to do a probe
control P no I didn't quite get it let's
do it again right there we go it's
returning 1-1 it's causing the bounce so
I'm going to do a control G go to the
definition of inflect one down here and
I can look okay the x1 is returning one
and the the y-component is returning -1
right
I can go to control G why is that
happening because the Y component is 331
and the maximum the the size of the
maximum Y the size of the height of the
screen is 330 so that's why it's being
inflected okay no now we have a bounce
if I want to be really brave about it I
could actually log everything on the
screen or log all the positions I can
just type blog here P right and now I
see a bunch of positions here right and
as I click on these positions I go to
the first one the second one the third
one again this is linked to the code and
linked to the execution context so as I
click on this I go to the log command
and I also set the execution context for
the entry that I'm manipulating so it's
all completely linked and navigable okay
so let's do something else here let me
let me get
rid of my balls here really quick zero I
mean I could have killed that so I'm
going to just do a ball out here in real
space and I'm going to get rid of the
log because I don't know what the
performance implications are of that
okay now we're going to make this
extensible method right so I'm going to
control gene on that now we're in there
and now I want to make P an argument but
P is a variable so it will change but
the initial P right is not an argument
so maybe we can create a p0 here drag
that of course it changed a little bit
because the holy terms changed and the
default random position value is based
on the identity of the holy term token
so if that ever changes the position
changes now I'm gonna make this an
argument so I think you know if you if
you're familiar with Brett Victor's own
herbal programming yes I think he does a
little bit of this in his essay too or
probably that's where I got the idea so
I'm going to turn that into an Arg okay
now position is an argument of fall and
what happens the position that I had is
transferred up here as an argument right
which would just which is the holy term
but now I can click on this and IRF I
can click on this if I set the position
to 0 the time to 0 right now I can click
on this and I can track it right now
that we can see that as we drag it the
the trajectory every like all the 200
frames that are being computed in the
physics simulation all update and in
real time basically ok so now we can do
the same thing with the the size so now
I can actually change the size now I'm
using instead of scrubbing on the the
code side thought I couldn't manipulate
directly now what about the velocity no
there's no you know I can build in this
the move command and the resize command
into the into the draw geometry logic
but I'm you know obviously geometries
don't usually have velocity so I need to
add something there
so I'm going to create a new variable
called v-0 I'm going to initialize
that's just going to be the the initial
value of the velocity and I'm going to
scrub that into a argument okay but of
course we you know I can change it up
here no problem but I wanted to be able
to change it over here in the diagram so
what we're going to do I'm going to save
this just in case of crashes I'm going
to type in we're gonna do a code
completion on this thing we're gonna
call draw back and what drive back does
is it draws vectors but of course it
needs commands so we're gonna draw the
velocity vector and we have to specify
the center of the vector which is P
right now what's kind of cool here is
now when I do tick and when i when i
scrub ontic I have to move my code down
again so I have no space you know you
can see the velocity vector that is the
velocity right it's just drawing it out
okay any more space actually give me
more space all right good okay but
what's cool here let me stop coming over
there taskbar let me give me more space
here now this velocity here let me make
sure that we can see it right is a point
the point is drawn on the screen the
point can be moved and the system will
reverse engineer how that point was came
into being finding a constant that it or
a holy term that it can rewrite based on
your movement so when I move this right
it's changing the velocity right and
that's not built into the system that's
just something we did ourselves and when
I when I stopped moving it rewrites the
velocity parameter of the ball call okay
so let me clamp that really quick - unit
you're in it alrighty now let's put more
balls on the screen all right
I put more balls in the screen a lot now
I'm gonna select this guy here and we
see that it has a velocity vector now
though because this @ symbol here
prepends the the drawback command it
only executes when the execution cut
when the debug execution context of the
ball method matches the the ball being
drawn okay so as we navigate through
this we can see the the vector change so
now we can change this guy and change
this guy here and change this guy and
then move them around of course because
we have our little ball editor here that
we can make this allows us to do that
okay so now we can just do it this whole
simulation we can actually do the same
thing with force drawback
with F and P let's make that red
okay now I can modify the the force but
actually what happens here is if I do
modify this force you see they're all
changing and why is that because forces
in an argument force is just something
that's embedded in the definition of
ball now I could go ahead and make a
force argument promote it to the to an
argument of ball and it would work as
you would expect it would be an argument
of ball than it every time I modified
this I wouldn't be modifying this up
here I'd be modifying something up here
okay all right so if we run this now
control R so we see that the balls are
kind of running they have the same force
acting on them but they have different
initial velocities and stuff and then if
I you know if I click on this it will
give me the last 200 frames from five
thirty six to seven thirty six and I can
step through those but I can't scrub
through the initial ones because you
know time travel is expensive and you
need to checkpoint and you don't want to
record forever okay so let me let me
save that off and let's restart it
so let's do another example here is that
me anyways okay so now we're just going
to draw some stuff on the screen and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
click on the screen up here so the
little mouse is here and if I control
click I will draw something on the
screen and it will just be a rectangle
so I click I draw a rectangle let me add
a little bit bigger right and then I can
scrub that into a circle I can move that
to the corner of the thing and I can
resize it to let's say six right and
then I can do another one this one I
want to actually be a rectangle so
that's fine thirty and then position
that to some size okay and then another
one here and what I'm doing is I'm
building a composite shape so I want
that to be a circle also positioned at
120 and 60 radius okay so now I put
three shapes on the screen and I've
placed them and I positioned them they
all have different colors because holy
terms or whatever but what we can do is
we can actually select this and then I
can control click on this shape and it
will do a union right and alls it does
is it moves the code around a little bit
and closing it makes it unique all right
and we can do a new call here too all
right so now I have this pill shape
right and now we want to abstract that
so I don't know if you're familiar with
Brett victor's create by abstracting so
this is kind of an example of that right
and he also used a shape too so I'm not
being incredibly original here but I
thought it was a cool demo anyways so
I'm going to create this sz0 to act as
the size of the pill and I'm just going
to just going to connect that here to
this one 2016 because that seems to be
repeated a lot in this shape so as I do
that you know so the the the tuple moves
up and the reference to the variable the
value moves down alright and we could do
the same thing here
I can drag the tuple components on all
of the the numeric references I can also
drag it on this one too because it's 30
and 60 s kind of like 30 but a little
bit greater and now let's see you if I
it works I can make it bigger no it's
not exactly right so well so we just go
ahead and scrub the minus sign again I
think this is part of Bret specters demo
too so not an original but it's kind of
cool to explore this idea so we do / -
right and now it works okay so now we
have a pill and it moves and I got to
make it a reasonable size though
50 50 50 I really should have
implemented snappier but I didn't okay
there you go alright so now we have a
pill right and now we need to make this
and now we need to create an abstraction
here so I'm going to create a tough pill
we turn holy okay and now I'm going to
drag this connect it to the last Union
and okay we get a call to pill and we
get a implementation of the pill method
right and the first thing we need is a
position so if I do that well that's not
useful
give me the keyboard back so I'm gonna
call translate the echo completion is
gonna mean some your location let's give
it a non weird location here all right
and then all I have to do is create the
p VAR the p variable up here give it a
holy term connect it to the translate
position and then make that a variable
aren't making an argument sorry right
now if I click on this I can move it
around and the P the the p value here
gets gets modified not the not a global
league not a global one and then I think
we need size but the size is wrong so we
need to correct the size a bit so it's
probably 50 plus 90 so the X is 140 and
this is 50 right because you have to add
in the circle with two so then we drag
that down here and now we have the size
and we make that a arg right and then it
appears down here but I'm not getting
the scrubbing behavior anymore right I
can I can scrub here I can scrub here
but I can't scrub the tuple and I don't
see the little dot that allows me to
resize in the editor and the problem is
that there's just not enough type
information this is like an a tube it's
not it's not a length to that allows you
to do the scrubbing right so this is
using some kind of backward type
inference inference algorithm and
sometimes you know you don't use SZ
enough I use as SC 0 fine it's a it's a
length 2 that could be scrubbed if it
was the thing I was scrubbing because
it's used here but SZ is just used to
create a Z 0 so I have to actually add a
notation in here ok
so I add an annotation now I can do it
now I can resize with a type annotation
and the final thing I need to do is add
a rotation to make it a real shape let's
just
rotate and whoa all right
I knew that might happen it's happened
before it just doesn't happen all the
time okay so I will now restart my demo
and start over again no I have it loaded
up somewhere here Dumbo - all right
we'll ignore this you just go away you
go away you go away and you go away all
right so
let me go ahead and add the pill so now
I have a pill shape here right with with
position size and radius right and all
the shapes that I had otherwise also had
those things let me make this bigger and
I could actually maximize the scanning
all right that's good right now I'm
going to create a shape on the screen
again as I started out of the demo draw
right and then I make it a circle right
now what's interesting here is that um
and then I can move this up right and I
can now that now that when I scrub the
shape it sits here because it has the
right method signature size position
size and radius so now that I put it
there I can give it a size we can make
another one see if I can just fill
directly here right do the same thing
well that's right it could also hit the
screen too
okay
and I could make this brown
and then make this the button color up
here that is not really good color
correction yeah let's make that
different right and now we have like oh
I guess this is a hamburger sculpture
and not as impressive as a Toby's demos
I think that I mean this is just coming
from a different direction okay so that
concludes my demo how much time do I
have ten minutes so you know I could let
me just finish up my talk here let's
yeah no I'm uh I had a feature recap but
I don't think you know maybe if you want
to pursue the slides offline that's
that's good but I had the pre skip built
in here so a lot of Technology went to
this demo and I'm not really talking
about technology today I'm talking about
you know sort of the live programming
experience but of course to do this
right we needed a virtual time machine I
used to call this glitch and I think it
sounds better as virtual time machine
it's like react for compilers so if
react doesn't have state and you know
that's that's why I react is it allows
you to do this like turn your retain
mode Dom into an immediate mode thing
right and we just add back to state and
that gives us the ability to write these
complex environments but also it gives
us a programming model for the language
I just demonstrated and we also have
this thing I call a type list type
system which has subtyping in generic so
I didn't really show that today but it
has full client-side type inference so
it will always and for the type and it
will never ask you for an annotation
unless you want special scrubbing
features okay and you know I showed off
this environment a px
it's a custom language and environment
with enhanced typography and we use the
DLR for dynamic code generation which
gives us a little bit of performance so
it's all native code at some point but
with a highly embellished runtime system
okay so I'm gonna conclude the talk I
want to conclude this here with the
obvious question it's just like I and I
think this is this was this question was
asked at Brett Victor's 2012 strange
talk and says what about if I'm writing
a compiler why should push my
then the idea being that you know this
kind of stuff looks cool when we're
doing 2d shapes right but you know you
don't really know how to scale it yet
and I think Brett's Bret's answer was
was a-telling and I think it's worth
repeating here is that there are these
artists design requirements for it could
be very good environment how do we
change programming to fit and that's
what I'm working on so thanks and I can
take questions though